the reason facebook ads don't work or
any ads mind everyone's is always
because of the content the content is
the variable of success
this portion is like with me so i think
this is when you need to get selfish
like you need to ask your question
hiring is guessing firing is knowing
like you got to go fast that's how you
get [ __ ] done that's how you figure
stuff out this is the television
and the television is the radio
40s [ __ ]
cool naomi why don't you get us started
yeah certainly so my name is naomi i'm
the marketing manager for the very salon
group and the invaders to winnipeg i
take care of our top line marketing
strategy all of our paid advertising um
social strategy all of that good stuff
um so i also manage a small team of two
people uh in our marketing department
and we pretty much take care of every
digital aspect of the business
and fun fact that i learned today and
naomi is actually at the company because
of uh some advice that you gave to
roberto back in 2019
i'm sure we have that as a talking point
in a little bit but colleen why don't
you get into your background a little
bit and what you do for the company yeah
so i'm colleen i'm the director of
education and business development for
the verde salon group i've also educated
at the aveda institute before i've
educated for other hair product lines as
well
and i helped rob kind of right from the
beginning he doesn't know how to do hair
and he went to hair school for a few
minutes but um so i've been there to
help him out with all the things that he
needs and uh yeah we've been a team
throughout this so
it's awesome
and roberta why don't you go ahead and
uh take it away
yeah it's gary thanks so much for your
time today i know you're launching
series two i'm a huge fan i've got uh i
got four v friends one and i'm waiting
for the drop that stupid game you just
put out has just got me locked in right
now i'm not paying attention to jeff too
much but uh but it's a lot of fun thanks
for taking this time today so i opened
up the uh the business back in 2017 um
with some help from nick and a
government grant that we got i was able
to attend um four d's in 2019 um hired
naomi right after that event and it
changed a lot for me really put a lot of
things in a different perspective for me
opened my eyes new opportunity a couple
um couple tips that you gave me uh
before i left we implemented it and it's
just it's done a lot for our business um
and i just wanted to have this
opportunity right now to have naomi and
colleen experience that as well we're
gonna be coming down to new york in june
um and just that whole experience too
was was really good for me so i'm really
looking forward to them experiencing it
as well um we're at a place now where we
um have like expanded so we opened our
second salon this is something that we
talked about when i was at 40s we opened
our second salon we also acquired a hair
school
and the two work really close together
so the hair school feeds the hair salons
gives us the opportunity to scale our
businesses and whatnot and we're kind of
at a place now where you know when i
came back to 4ds back in 2019 we're on
the verge or just on that doorstep of
taking
our next step to expand our business and
we feel like we're back there again now
um and you know there's this marketing
piece is going to be huge for us um joe
and the team and ourselves here talked
about some of the things that we're
thinking of implementing we're going to
want to run some of those by you and uh
and just get your take on it
i totally understand i'm so happy to be
here with you three
thank you appreciate it
yeah so one of the things that uh got me
fired up was not only that um you know
he's a second time guest of ours but um
the team
uh is interested in building out a
podcast and uh we got to talking a
little bit about how we use podcast
strategically or episodic content
strategically throughout the vayner x
organization whether it's marketing for
the now or your podcast experience or
what we're doing with building while
flying where we really go out and we
find the guests that we want to become
our customers or our next employees or
something like that um so rob why don't
you go ahead and launch in a little bit
to kind of what you were thinking about
in terms of a podcast and maybe we can
jam a little bit on seeing if we can uh
enhance it make it better help you roll
it out
yeah i was being very top-line that
naomi could speak further to it um but
the idea is you know there's i think
there's two people that we're marketing
to marketing to our guests that come
into the salon to get their hair done
and buy our product but then there's
also other salons
and our brand of veda that we're a part
of that we want to market you to
position ourselves as leaders within the
industry that will do very well for us
with the veda down the road as
eventually i want to get to the point
where we're going to be distributing a
beta for canada
and further to that being able to
position ourselves as professionals or
leaders in industry for to salons so
that we can attract some of their senior
talents as well to come work with us
something that really is going to help
the the wheel continue to move um and i
think you know the
idea of being able to interview people
and really highlight who they are and
then as well sure our expertise would
work really well but i'll let naomi
maybe get a little bit further into that
yeah absolutely one thing that's really
interesting about the beauty industry is
that uh there's a lot of kind of like
old school thought like there's a lot of
salon owners who are just getting to the
point where they realize that they have
to post on instagram consistently um so
a lot of the marketing in the beauty
industry is very old school because a
lot of salon owners are hair stylists
they don't necessarily have a business
background or a marketing background so
i think that establishing our brand and
really establishing ourselves within the
broader salon network will do us a lot
of good as rob just mentioned and i
think that diving a little bit deeper
more so into like the
business side of beauty
as far as operations goes as far as
marketing goes as far as you know the
takeaways
and learning we've done through scaling
our business opening a second location i
think we have a lot of
knowledge and a lot of expertise that we
can potentially share with others in the
industry and i think that that would be
probably my main focus in putting
together a podcast
and all for
people to do what
so the idea would be is
really
sharing our expertise on the business
side to then gain
we want to be the forerunners within our
industry to be able to speak to all
these all the business side domains so
that it puts us in a position to attract
more talent and also in a position with
aveda to show that we're the forerunners
within our own country to have them
build a trust with them then further do
business with them down the road
the when you say the betas
sorry aveda aveda is the brand the hair
brand the hair company brand
so they're owned by estee lauder um
they're out of minneapolis um and
at one time there was a distribution in
canada which they bought back
it's proving that it doesn't work very
well for them to run it out of the us in
canada and we want to be able to
position ourselves down the road to be
the forerunners to say these guys know
what they're talking about we should go
a little bit further with them and start
talking distribution that's the kpi of
the business leadership understood i
would run linkedin ads of clips from the
podcast against the employees that work
at the highest levels of avida
so when it comes to creating the content
on the podcast
what's the best what's the best form to
do that is interviewing the best way to
do that or interviewing you making
pretend that you're the b2b magazine of
the industry like
one of the reasons i do well is when i
make content i make content
there's never a moment in the last 15
years including wine library tv where i
would review wines that we had a lot of
and i would pan them
which was [ __ ] insane my dad
literally lost his mind
first
the first year my dad literally was like
look you are a wild dude and everything
you do is right but this one can't be
right i'm like it's right
he's like no no you're wrong here it is
we were selling 30 cases a week of this
wine you put it on the show
you said that it sucks [ __ ] and now we
sell four bottles a week you were wrong
i'm like look at our overall business
they're not going to buy that because it
does suck [ __ ] look what they're buying
so
what
what you do is you interview people but
every time you interview people every
selfish want and need that you want from
aveda executives kids to go to the
school employees from your competitors
to join you every one of those things
that are running through your mind
you never act on them
you act as if you left this business
and are now hosting a b2b show for the
industry
and you're trying to get the best
ratings on serious radio
you do that
and your subconscious will still make
you go a little bit to the business side
naomi will find those moments we clip
them
we link to the full podcast
and you run ads against people in your
industry and very very quickly six
months to a year it [ __ ] matters
makes sense
yep
is there a lot of that going on garrett
with uh i know marketing from the now's
a different beast but there's so many
people across the understand
yeah
you know it's 100
not even 99.
yeah that was an eye opener rancho
mentioned that
yeah yeah i mean
i i definitely did not want to do that
today for 30 minutes some to you know i
this launch is pissing me off and i got
a lot going on but you know
we're doing that because a
we don't do business with the everlane
cmo
you know and that's an opportunity but b
one moment one second is the right clip
on linkedin we run a thousand dollars
worth of ads against cmos and two people
decide to reach out to vayner x and want
to do business
that's cool
so there's two other kind of themes gary
that i think that being said the reason
i said six months to a year is that's 15
years of me putting out content at scale
and being historically correct that
gives us that level of conversion it's
going to take now what's nice though
is your industry is so niche and no
one's doing like it that it'll take six
months to a year
but you know this you don't need a lot
to happen for it to be a real good use
of your time and money
and there's going to be there's going to
be 14 things that happen they have no
idea nor do i
a local newscaster thinks that's
interesting uh the paper has a slow week
and they just want to do a profile and a
business person uh an executive you
never thought you could afford to get
is burnt out at you know procter and
gamble and his and his husband and wife
is moving to your part of the woods and
like [ __ ] it this is creative and
interesting i don't care that i have to
make you know more than half my salary
i'm moving towards the tail end of my
career i'm moving this middle of nowhere
place compared to being in you know
unilever in new york city i'm [ __ ]
i'm going to reach out to these people
and this guy and see if he wants to do
like it leads to so much
yeah i agree with you some of those um
some of those things that we implemented
after we came back from 4ds wasn't the
actual result from what we implemented
it was all the things all the synergies
that happened afterwards from it so that
was cool
cool joe we're going to jump into this
on the b to c side where are you with
tick tock
uh
i asked a question
um so i definitely know we need to be
utilizing it more we post about once a
day which i know is not the best way to
use like utilize it um by the way one
day still has me like literally with the
way you reacted i'm like literally i
thought the word week was going to come
out instead of day
one a day is already
a huge accomplishment just to give the
three of you context
yeah absolutely and that's content that
we take and we put it anywhere that
vertical video makes sense um so we're
really maximizing what we're putting out
across platforms um
and we just haven't even seen are you
making tick tocks or not really
i would say we're making tick tocks uh i
definitely i definitely have found that
you know more polished content does
better on other platforms whereas tick
tock you know
even if you're running an ad if you're
doing organic it's got to be a tick tock
so that's definitely something i've
learned um over the last like year or so
of making content on that platform um so
that's something that's really critical
and then you sense that there's an
opportunity there oh yeah absolutely and
i even just got some very good
information from the conversation we
just had with jeff as well so
they did just launch uh or during the
pandemic they launched that dtc product
error that could fit into their strategy
for for social media it's uh
kind of in various different
conversations we've had from a research
perspective you typically go in on like
you gotta white label something so that
you can kind of maximize
your margins and have a product that
consumers can latch on and really start
to own the game so um rob why don't you
talk a little bit about the at-home
product you guys created and maybe
that's a something we can sink our teeth
into in terms of talking to consumers
yeah for sure
just based on the tick tock um
conversation for a second they laughed
at me gary i was talking to talk when
you were talking about it they're
laughing at me but it's done very well
for us and um we've seen actually
through the school side of the majority
of our leads are coming through tick
tock so i guess one of the questions too
that we can throw in is how do we double
down create the content we're a team of
three between three businesses how do we
double down create the content so that
we've got enough for tick-tock but then
again enough for everything else
make less profit
say it again
make less profit
alluding to
hire another person
yeah
that was the advice you gave me the
first time
i didn't i love that i'm still
consistent
consistent three years later um yeah but
the good news is
it's a dream job for
you know without knowing laws of like
like for a 16 to 22 year old that's
interested in this subject matter it's a
dream job
to make two tick tocks a day
got it you could also
hire someone
to just search
locally
or not locally
for influencers
and try to get good deals on people it's
a lot of hand-to-hand combat dm-ing them
this that the other thing but it's a
great arbitrage
i have a quick question to you gary
what's the best way to find the people
you want to hire as content creators to
just know like oh they're they're
amazing at what they do
search hashtags on tick tock in your
subject matter
find people that you subjectively the
three of you like who don't have a lot
of followers
and dm them and say do you want a job
so you find someone that you three
you're like wow that was a good hair
video or whatever am i right
it doesn't even have to be a hair you
could literally be like wow that was a
good eggs video and she has great hair
like you could play this a couple of
different ways
and and then you're like oh she only has
700 followers
yeah i think that's a good idea
and this could be done remote you know
right
yeah i mean think about her
people in college right now are
having tick tocks go viral like to
gary's point it's a dream job if you're
in college you can make side money
making tick tocks
forget about it that's awesome that
didn't exist when i was in college
and and even better the year before
college or the year after even more
interesting like different option
psychology
that i like a lot
for sure
are you talking verde at home
yeah
sorry uh varidate homes are um our
direct consumer so this is something
that we developed i apologize because i
want to get this down in my head verde
is a brand that's owned by them right
no so verde is our brand aveda is the
brand
right i'm sorry i'm sorry right so
dyslexic enough that i got confused
got it so we sell it it's our school is
an aveda school so we we have like it's
not a franchise but if we're allowed to
be innovative school contractually and
our brand is verde which is the salon
and we salivate it in the salon and use
their hair color
so over the pandas
exclusively
and is that kind of the punch line to be
a school
yeah and that's because they're feeding
their brand is strong enough and they're
helping feed or the brand is helping
clothes and that's why you make that
deal
no different than frank i understand big
big point of difference for us and as of
june we'll be the only available
institute in canada so we'll be able to
market ourselves as invaders
we're emerging hairstylists or even
current ones if that brand carries that
level of weight it does yeah that's what
it does and now there it is your product
your private label product that's right
and is that a veda inside or something
else
uh well we carry aveda products inside
so we sell exclusively our products
inside the verdict juice the formula the
dtc products yes it's available
yep
right so any people ever done a good job
enough
with building a private label in their
ecosystem that they got upset about it
um no
no as a matter of fact they asked us
about it um they were interested in you
know we had one of their national
international educators come to the
salon to do a class they heard about our
the product that we put out verdi at
home and they were actually asking us to
help them um you know because of that
the at-home part right
that's right different than just sitting
on the shelf that's where you're going
to be
understand that's right so that's the
does that come with like
is that just a pure dtc or is there a
level of like you guys hand holding and
helping people because you have school
dna
i don't understand the question i'm sure
so one thing i've always been fascinated
with ddc products is the level of
scaling virtual
um handholding and experience not just
getting the product
yes so there was an aspect of them that
we thought was one of our points of
difference which is you can buy the
product we can ship it to you but before
that even happens you can have a virtual
consultation with the natural hair
stylist and without guessing and right
was that did that work is that good like
people like that during that pandemic it
worked but then once we opened again and
then brick and mortar became the thing
again it completely died out so i think
it's a good right so we think it's a
good product there's definitely a market
in it because it's a billion dollar
industry um home color you know buying
home color big difference in price point
it obviously exploded because of covid
so it still might be a nice base and to
your point if you run ads against
different income levels or figure out
how to target the right people
there's still a big industry there
there there should be and this is the
part we haven't been able to crack
because post covid we were marketing to
our we're marketing to our guests who
were buying it throughout the pandemic
the problem is those guests already have
the context of people wanting to be that
are willing to pay the extra to be a
guest you need a whole review
so that's the direction we went in
afterwards but we couldn't crack it yeah
have you been running
facebook ads
facebook instagram yeah
what about tick tock
not on tick tock and is facebook
challenging because you can't really
market in the ios 15 and all that cookie
and stuff yeah
and because creative is the variables so
let me tell you what you should do
you should make tick tocks
that are
about the with the product make at least
two more of them so i need you to make
four tick tocks a day so you're gonna
have to figure this out roberto like
let's play it out though two of those i
think are from verde
all organic different value props
right like
like you got to be very creative like
naomi the video's got to have like four
tim hortons coffees there like the
expensive ones and say
you can afford these now because you're
using very at home and not going to like
you got to like really be clever around
the value proposition like
you know like you almost have to go
outside you know how on tick tock
there's that guy that comes up to people
with expensive cars you almost have to
like do videos where like these are
people people drive this when they go to
the salon and obviously have to be
careful because you have a salon
business so you have to be thoughtful
but
bottom line is
do tick-tock ads to build the brand when
it goes viral you turn it into a
performance dtc ad so you take the
essence of the ad and you tweak the
wording you add the call to action
you run that as a tick tock ad and as a
linkedin as a instagram and facebook ad
because it's been proven that humans are
interested in the content the reason
facebook ads don't work or any ads mind
everyone's is always because of the
content
the content is the variable of success
right it's the substance like you know
the reason people don't marry each other
after a date is that they didn't go well
but you got to the date
right same with advertising right like
your facebook and instagram is right
it's just the content wasn't right for
that instance
tick tock is so built on people's
interest that you know there's people
that are interested then you just scale
it by running ads on all three platforms
use your knowledge how platforms are
slightly different you might use
different words you might play right the
slang is different for tick-tock where
it's young versus facebook where it's
older but you still get the essence of
the content this is why making four tick
tocks a day is everything because you're
getting the consumer insights
yeah absolutely that makes total sense
um the other thing i had a question
about in regards to that is the level of
customizability because we thought that
that was a major point of difference
obviously with the consultation and all
of those additional pieces um but what
we found was that
when you know a lot of people expressed
interest clicked through got to the
landing page but then didn't take the
step of booking a consultation people
seemed to just want to purchase the item
and then have it be done
when it was working or now
um both i would say
yeah i mean i think you've got to run
creative ads that play up the
consultation what was happening
before was
i mean
right like hey like i was on a girls
marketing zoom
with like all the cmo mafia ladies that
i'm friends with in their 50s and 60s
and we were doing wine one night in
covid four months in and the first 45
minutes was hair coloring they were just
making fun of me every five minutes like
are you bored yet gary i'm like no i'm
kind of i'm greying i might have to do
that too like you know we were having
some fun it was just the culture right
that culture is over to your point
um so you're gonna have to find the
people that are actually interested in
it by running ads that
feature that value problem yeah
absolutely you're just gonna need more
at-bats on tick-tock that is going to be
the punchline of this conversation that
is the big breakthrough right now
and there's a 99 chance that after
they've done coloring their hair with
your product they're going to post it to
tic toc or instagram anyway so maybe
there's a way you can incentivize them
somehow
give me your tick tock address just so i
can see you posting the product or
something like that just figure out a
way to get their social data so you can
kind of plug in with them a little bit
comment on their stuff you know just
engage with them
absolutely the posting more content on
tick tock is going to give us the
insight he dennis what's going to work
and what's not going to work
you